It's a really good idea to be familiar with some common algorithms for
processing values in a loop. You've seen a couple of them already. You've seen
how to compute the average of a sequence of inputs and you've seen how to find
the largest element. There are quite a few more like that, counting matches,
finding the first match, position of the first match, finding all matches. And
so on, and so on. Instead of me tediously telling you something about each of
them, we've prepared a fact sheet where you can find the pseudo-code and an
example for easy reference. And Sara will practice a couple of those with you.
The point is that you want to be familiar with what algorithms are out there,
so that you can adapt them as necessary.